Para averiguarlo, he estudiado a gente a la que denomino "originales".
Los originales son no conformistas,
personas que no solo tienen nuevas ideas
sino que las defienden.
Son personas que destacan y comunican.
Los originales impulsan la creatividad y el cambio en el mundo.
Son personas que desean apostar por algo.
Y no se parecen en nada a lo que imaginaba.
Quiero mostrar hoy tres cosas que he aprendido
a la hora de reconocer a los originales
y convertirme un poco más como ellos.
Así que la primera razón para pasar de Warby Parker
era por ser muy lento para despegar del suelo.
Uds. están muy familiarizados con la mente de un procrastinador.
Debo confesarles algo. Soy lo contrario. Soy un "precrastinador".
Sí, eso es un término real.
Conocen el pánico que se siente horas antes de una fecha límite importante
cuando no se ha hecho nada todavía.
Eso es lo que siento yo unos meses antes de la fecha.
(Risas)
Esto comenzó temprano. De niño, tomaba muy en serio los juegos de Nintendo.
Me despertaba a las 5,
empezaba a jugar y no paraba hasta dominarlos.
Con el tiempo estaba tan fuera de control que un periódico local vino
e hizo un reportaje sobre el lado oscuro de Nintendo, protagonizada por mí.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Desde entonces, he perdido el pelo.
(Risas)
Pero esto me sirvió mucho en la universidad,
porque terminé mi tesis de grado cuatro meses antes de la fecha límite.
Y estaba orgulloso, hasta que hace pocos años,
tuve una estudiante, Jihae, que vino a mí y me dijo:
"Tengo ideas más creativas cuando estoy procrastinando".
Y yo: "Bien, pero ¿dónde están los cuatro documentos que me debes?"
(Risas)
Ella era una de las estudiantes más creativas,
y como psicólogo organizacional, compruebo este tipo de ideas.
Así que la desafié a que recabara algunos datos.
Fue a un grupo de empresas.
Ella propone rellenar encuestas sobre la frecuencia con que posponen cosas.
Luego pide a los jefes que califiquen lo creativos e innovadores que son.
Y, por supuesto, los precrastinadores, como yo,
que hacen todo al principio
son calificados como menos creativos
que las personas que procrastinan moderadamente.
Por eso quiero saber qué pasa con los procrastinadores crónicos.
Ella dijo: "No sé. No cumplimentaron mi encuesta".
(Risas)
No, aquí están nuestros resultados.
De hecho, las personas que esperan hasta el último minuto
están tan ocupados perdiendo el tiempo que no tienen ninguna idea nueva.
Y por el otro lado, las personas que compiten
están en tal frenesí de ansiedad que carecen de pensamientos originales.
Hay una zona de acción donde los originales parecen vivir.
¿Por qué es esto?
Tal vez la gente original simplemente tiene malos hábitos de trabajo.
Tal vez la procrastinación no genera creatividad.
Para averiguarlo, hemos diseñado algunos experimentos.
Pedimos a la gente generar nuevas ideas de negocio,
y contamos con lectores independientes
para evaluar la creatividad y utilidad.
Y a algunos de ellos se les pidió realizar la tarea de forma inmediata.
A otros aleatoriamente se les asignó posponer las cosas
colgando el Minesweeper ante ellos
cada 5 o 10 minutos.
Y, por supuesto, los procrastinadores moderados
son 16 % más creativos que los otros dos grupos.
Minesweeper es impresionante, pero no es el impulsor del efecto,
porque si uno juega primero antes de aprender la tarea,
no hay impulso en la creatividad.
Es solo al saber que vas a trabajar en este problema,
y luego uno empieza a procrastinar,
pero la tarea sigue siendo activa en la parte posterior de su mente,
se empieza a incubar.
La procrastinación ofrece tiempo para considerar las ideas divergentes,
para pensar en formas no lineales, para hacer saltos inesperados.
Por eso solo al terminar estos experimentos,
empecé a escribir un libro sobre los originales,
y pensé: "Este es el momento ideal para ser autodidacta en procrastinar,
al escribir un capítulo sobre la procrastinación".
Así que metaprocrastiné,
y como cualquier precrastinador que se precie,
me desperté a la mañana siguiente
e hice una lista de tareas pendientes con pasos para procrastinar.
(Risas)
Y luego trabajé diligentemente
hacia mi meta de no progresar hacia mi meta.
Empecé a escribir el capítulo de la procrastinación,
y un día, estando a medio camino,
literalmente, lo guardé en mitad de la frase
durante meses.
Era una agonía.
Pero cuando volví a ella, tenía todo tipo de nuevas ideas.
Como dijo Aaron Sorkin,
"Ud. lo llama la procrastinación. Yo lo llamo pensamiento".
Y en el camino descubrí
que muchos de los grandes originales de la historia eran los procrastinadores.
Como Leonardo da Vinci.
Trabajó de manera intermitente durante 16 años
en la Mona Lisa.
Se sentía como un fracasado.
Escribió tanto en su diario.
Sin embargo, algunos de los desvíos que tomó en la óptica
transformaron su forma de modelar la luz
convirtiéndolo en un pintor mucho mejor.
¿Qué hay de Martin Luther King, Jr.?
La noche antes del discurso más grande de su vida,
la marcha sobre Washington,
estaba pasadas las 3, reescribiéndolo.
Sentado en el público esperando su turno para subir al escenario,
todavía tomaba notas y subrayaba las líneas.
Cuando sube al escenario, en el minuto 11,
deja sus comentarios preparados
y pronuncia cuatro palabras que cambiaron el curso de la historia:
"Yo tengo un sueño".
Eso no estaba en el guion.
Al retrasar la tarea de finalizar el discurso hasta el último minuto,
dejó abierta una gama más amplia de posibles ideas.
Y debido a que el texto no estaba escrito en piedra,
tenía la libertad para improvisar.
Procrastinar es un vicio si está vinculado a la productividad,
pero puede ser una virtud para la creatividad.
Lo que se ve en muchos grandes originales
es que son rápidos para empezar, pero lentos para terminar.
Y esto es lo que me perdí con Warby Parker.
Cuando estaban reptando durante seis meses,
los miré y le dije:
"Muchas otras compañías han empezado a vender gafas en línea".
Perdieron la ventaja de ser los pioneros.
Pero de lo que no me di cuenta de que en todo ese tiempo
intentaban encontrar la manera de conseguir que la gente
se sintiera cómoda comprando gafas en línea.
Y resulta que la ventaja del movimiento pionero es todo un mito.
Un estudio clásico de más de 50 categorías de productos,
que comparaba a los pioneros que crearon el mercado
con los mejoradores que presentaron algo diferente y mejor.
Lo que se ve es que los primeros motores tenían una tasa de error del 47 %,
en comparación con el solo el 8 % de los mejorados.
Miren Facebook, esperando construir una red social
hasta después de MySpace y Friendster.
Miren Google, esperando durante años después de AltaVista y Yahoo.
Es mucho más fácil mejorar sobre la idea de otra persona
que crear algo nuevo desde cero.
La lección que aprendí es que para ser original no hay que ser el primero.
Solo hay que ser diferente y mejor.
Pero esa no fue la única razón por la que pasé de Warby Parker.
También estaban llenos de dudas.
Tenían planes de copias de seguridad,
y eso me hizo dudar de que tenían el valor de ser originales,
porque esperaba que los originales lucieran así.
(Risas)
Ahora, en la superficie,
mucha gente original parece de confianza,
pero tras los bastidores,
sienten el mismo temor y duda que el resto de nosotros.
Ellos simplemente lo manejan de forma diferente.
Déjenme mostrarles: Esto una representación
de cómo el proceso creativo funciona para la mayoría de nosotros.
(Risas)
En mi investigación he descubierto que hay dos tipos diferentes de duda.
Duda de uno mismo y la duda de la idea en sí.
La duda en uno mismo es paralizante.
Te lleva al bloqueo.
Pero la duda de la idea es energizante.
Motiva a probar, experimentar, perfeccionar,
al igual que lo hizo MLK.
Y así, la clave para ser original
es solo una cosa simple
evitar el salto del paso tres al cuarto paso.
En lugar de decir: "Soy una mierda",
uno dice: "Los primeros borradores son siempre basura,
y no estoy allí todavía".
Entonces, ¿cómo se llega allí?
Bueno, hay una pista
en el navegador de Internet que usan.
Podemos predecir el rendimiento de su trabajo y su compromiso
con solo saber qué navegador web usan.
A algunos de Uds. no les gustarán los resultados de este estudio.
(Risas)
Pero hay evidencias sólidas de que los usuarios de Firefox y Chrome
superan con mucho a los usuarios de Internet Explorer y Safari.
Sí.
(Aplausos)
También permanecen en sus trabajos el 15 % más largo, por cierto.
¿Por qué? No es una ventaja técnica.
Los 4 grupos de navegadores tienen un promedio de velocidad de escritura similar
y también tienen niveles similares de conocimiento de la computadora.
Se trata de cómo se llega al navegador.
Si se usa Internet Explorer o Safari,
los instalados por omisión en el equipo,
acepta la opción por omisión.
Si quieren Firefox o Chrome, ponen en duda el valor por omisión
al cuestionar si hay una opción diferente por ahí,
y tener recursos para descargar un nuevo navegador.
Cuando la gente sabe de este estudio dice:
"Bien, si quiero mejorar en mi trabajo, ¿solo debo actualizar mi navegador?"
(Risas)
No, se trata de ser el tipo de persona
que toma la iniciativa de poner en duda el valor por omisión
y buscar una mejor opción.
Y si lo hacen así,
obtendrán lo contrario a un déjà vu.
Hay un nombre para eso, el "vujà dé".
(Risas)
Vujà es cuando vemos algo ya visto muchas veces
y, de repente, lo vemos de otra forma.
Es una guionista que mira el guion de una película
que no logra la luz verde desde hace más de medio siglo.
En todas las versiones pasadas, la protagonista era una reina malvada.
Pero Jennifer Lee empieza a preguntarse si eso tiene sentido.
Vuelve a escribir el primer acto,
reinventa al villano como un héroe atormentado
y Frozen se convierte en la película animada más exitosa de la historia.
Hay un mensaje simple en esta historia.
Cuando duden, no abandonen.
(Risas)
¿Qué pasa con el miedo?
Los originales sienten miedo, también.
Tienen miedo de fracasar,
pero lo que los diferencia del resto de nosotros
es que aún tienen más miedo de no intentarlo.
Saben que pueden fallar al iniciar un negocio que puede quebrar
o al iniciar un negocio en general.
Saben que en el largo plazo, nuestros mayores pesares no son nuestras acciones
sino nuestras inacciones.
Lo que deseamos poder hacer de nuevo, si miramos la ciencia,
son las oportunidades no realizadas.
Elon Musk me dijo hace poco que no pensaba que Tesla tendría éxito.
Estaba seguro de que los primeros lanzamientos de SpaceX
fallarían al entrar en órbita, y mucho más al volver,
pero era demasiado importante como para no intentarlo.
Y muchos de nosotros, si tenemos una idea importante,
no nos molestamos en intentarlo.
Pero tengo buenas noticias para Uds.
No les juzgarán por sus malas ideas.
Muchas personas piensan que sí.
Si analizamos todas las industrias
y preguntamos a la gente por su mejor idea, por su propuesta más importante,
el 85 % de ellos se queda en silencio en lugar de hablar.
Tienen miedo a situaciones embarazosas, a parecer estúpidos.
¿Pero saben qué? Los originales tienen muchas malas ideas,
toneladas de ellas, de hecho.
Tomen el tipo que inventó esto.
¿Importa que se le ocurriera una muñeca parlante tan espeluznante
que aterra no solo a los niños sino a los adultos también?
No, celebramos a Thomas Edison por ser pionero en la bombilla.
(Risas)
Si miramos a través de los sectores,
los originales más importantes son los que más fallan,
porque son los que más intentos hacen.
Tomemos a los compositores clásicos, el mejor de los mejores.
¿Por qué algunos tienen más páginas en las enciclopedias que otros
y también sus composiciones se editan más veces?
Uno de los mejores predictores
es la gran cantidad de composiciones que generan.
Cuanto más salida hacia fuera, más variedad se obtiene
y mejor serán sus posibilidades de tropezar con algo realmente original.
Incluso los tres íconos de la música clásica: Bach, Beethoven y Mozart,
crearon cientos y cientos de composiciones
hasta llegar a un número mucho más reducido de obras maestras.
Ahora, Uds. pueden preguntarse,
¿cómo este hombre pudo hacerse grande sin hacer tanto?
No sé cómo lo hizo Wagner.
Sin embargo, para la mayoría, si queremos ser más originales,
tenemos que generar más ideas.
Los fundadores de Warby Parker, al buscar un nombre para su empresa,
querían algo sofisticado, único, sin asociaciones negativas
para construir una marca,
y probaron más de 2000 posibilidades
antes de finalmente llegar
a Warby y Parker.
Así que al poner todo esto en relación, se ve que los originales
no son tan diferentes del resto de nosotros.
Sienten miedo y duda. Ellos procrastinan.
Tienen malas ideas.
Y, a veces, a pesar de esas cualidades, sino a causa de ellas
tienen éxito.
Así que cuando vean esas cosas, no cometan el mismo error que yo.
No los excluyan.
Y cuando les toque a Uds., no serán tampoco excluidos.
Saber ser rápidos para iniciar, pero lentos para terminar
puede aumentar su creatividad,
pueden automotivarse al dudar de sus ideas
y abrazar el miedo al fracaso al intentarlo.
Y se necesitan muchas malas ideas para tener buenas.
Ser original no es fácil,
pero no tengo ninguna duda sobre esto:
es la mejor manera de mejorar el mundo que nos rodea.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)